Ukraine's capital has become a
battleground protestors sent tires
alight and central Kiev only meters away
from lines of riot police all day long
the streets around Independence Square
were the scene of pitched battles
protesters hurled fire bombs and rocks
police responded with tear gas stun
grenades and the protesters safe live
ammunition in the afternoon the
government brought in armored vehicles
many feared the violence could spiral
out of control from the European Union
came warnings and threats of sanctions
if the situation continues to worsen we
are generally concerned about where
these developments are taking Ukraine
and you'll continue following close of
these developments as well as assessing
possible actions by the European Union
and consequences for our relations with
that country Germany's foreign minister
who is in Montreux for an international
conference on Syria called for an end to
the violence give out is Canada's and
violence is not the answer not in
Ukraine not for either side we have made
clear to President Yanukovych that we
cannot condone a violent response by the
government in Ukraine which simply
widens and worsens the suffering for
more and more people to mention sue
chardon come in the afternoon President
Viktor Yanukovych held talks with the
main opposition leaders to diffuse the
violence but with both sides calling
each other criminals and terrorists
there's little hope of compromise